NEARLY TOOK THE HEAD OFF OF ARE
THE ZONE.
SEATTLE ICES IT.TOP LINE
WITH PATRICK KANE.
CAN NOT BREAK UP CONFUSE ME FORR
SEATTLE
NEARLY
PUCK.
AND  IS FREE.
SHOT SHOT
WENT WIDE, THE
SHSH
FIRST INTERMISSION.
IT HAS BEEN STREAMLINE HOCKEY
SOTHE ASTING,
LIKE NO OTHER.
ON STANDING STILL.
LANKINEN THINGS HE WILL GO TO
IN IS A PLUS STUFF, ON THE
CALL OF .
AND THE OPPORTUNITY HERE WHERE
HE GETS  ON
IT.
GETTING THE BACK DOWN GOING BAC
HAWKS, THERE IS JONES,
SIZE OF
KIRBY DAPIZZA GUY?
>> CHRIS: I SHOT AND, EDDIE: W?
THREE ON THE
BOARD AND YOU ARE ANY PLAYER.
ESPECIALLY A YOUNG PLAYER THAT
TO
DEBR, BLOCK AND
BANGED OFF CHECKMEISTER
AND THE  INTERCEPTED THERE.
THERE IS VLASIC AGAIN N
WALL.
BACK END PASS, STROME COMING
CRAS LESS.
>> CHRIS: YEAH.
>> EDDIE: JONES OFF OF TOUND.
OFF OF THE MATTER
OF, WHAT, 15
SECONDS?
CARRIES IT
OVER.
HOMES, ULTRAFAST
EXIT THE ZONE.
THE HAWKS.
DACH AND LAFFERTY, HERE, THE
SHOT,  WAITS, HE WAITS, THE
BLACKHAWKS, BACK
UP, BACK USENDS IT BACK TO